your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate
and your level of stress or calm the
person who's constantly feeling fear
because they believe something out there
is going to get them
then they're more
more susceptible to things in their
outer environment than their immune
system is compromised
the fat on your body is not your friend
it
stores toxins that's one risk factor
it increases inflammation wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can hack
your body for incredible health enjoy
okay let's kick it off with hack number
one protect your gut with dr steven
gundry
we know that there are ways to give
these good guys like eckhermancia what
they like to eat
and they love resistant starches they
love tubers
like yams like jikama like tarot root
like
yucca or yucca they love
mushrooms and there's a beautiful recent
study out of
south asia of people basically having a
90
reduction in alzheimer's if you eat two
cups of mushrooms a week
what so there is this incredible
compound in mushrooms uh
i'll probably fracture it thione
thionine that actually crosses the
blood-brain barrier better than
turmeric curcumin and actually protects
against neuroinflammation and
it turns out that mushrooms absolutely
positively
feed these friendly bacteria and
mushrooms contain this compound called
spermidine
it's a polyamine that study after study
shows promotes longevity okay so
those are some of the things also
inulin-containing compounds
so inulin is present in chicory you can
buy inulin made out of yaekon root
and any store as a sweetener so inulin
feeds acrimoncia and so it's present in
chicory it's present in radicchio
belgian endive
jerusalem artichokes sunchokes they're
just pure
inulin so the more of this stuff you eat
the more of this bug you're going to
grow so that's number one
so eat for them number two exercise
beautiful study in women women have
more alzheimer's disease than men and
so you look at an exercise
program in women women who exercise
regularly routinely
kind of from mid-life on have a 90
reduction in alzheimer's whoa and
compared to women who don't exercise
routine
and in the women who are going to get
alzheimer's
it's 11 years later than
if they didn't exercise so i mean think
about that if we had a drug
that had a 90 reduction in alzheimer's
yeah
how much would we pay for that you know
you and i would be popping that yeah
every day uh we wouldn't have 40 billion
dollars wasted on amyloid drugs
but it's available by housework by
gardening
by getting a dog and walking it twice
okay that's interesting so when you say
housework why do you say that i think
people be confused by that
it turns out that give me an example my
my mother actually scrubbed her floors
until
the day she died at 90 even though there
were
swifters and things like that and she
did it
as an exercise program exercise
changes the gut microbiome to a
friendly microbiome meditation
yoga changes the gut microbiome
seems impossible it's so interesting
that they're in a two-way communication
yeah
yeah it literally and there's there's
even some really cool stuff that yoga
postures
uh actually move this
microbiome around in your gut and
they actually get signals probably
electrical signals
so all these chakras that you know in
eastern medicine
it's probably all this part of this
really amazing communication system that
western medicine is just going
oh come on that's all voodoo yeah
because we couldn't measure it before
yeah so exercise is really important
lastly i really want people to have a
brain wash day at least once a week
so in the last couple of years we've
learned
that there is a lymph system in the
brain
called the glymphatic system and it no
one actually believed it existed but now
it exists and the brain actually in deep
sleep
which happens very early in the sleep
cycle goes through a
literal wash cycle it shrinks by about
20 percent
and all of these toxins like amyloid
like
tau like bad pieces of protein
are actually squeezed out of the brain
like wringing out a sponge
and it happens in deep sleep and it
happens early in the sleep cycle
so we have to have a lot of blood flow
to our brain to do that the brain uses
huge amounts of blood flow but we have
to have even more
so the evidence is that you need about a
three or four
hour window before the last meal of your
day
before you go to sleep why because
digestion is actually really energy
expensive so we
put huge amounts of blood flow down into
our gut
if you eat near the time you go to bed
that blood flow is down in your
intestines
and it doesn't go up to your brain so
there's actually a recent study of
men who had unstable angina or heart
attack
and they followed those men who ate late
at night
had a much higher incidence of a new
engine or new heart heart attack and so
they're all really actually
interconnected so
one day a week i asked people finish
your last meal
at six o'clock if you go to bed at say
10 right if it's
11 finish it at seven do not snack
before bedtime and allow
yourself to have a brainwash better yet
skip a meal
and that gets in probably to the fourth
point
you've got to have periods of extended
lengths of time between
eating we were supposed to go
prolonged periods of time before our
next meal
and break fast we've talked about this
before it ruins your
you know your morning stuff was you
break your fast
and there's no definition of when you
know it's supposed to be breakfast
that was from the dear old kellogg's
cornflake company
telling people they had to eat breakfast
hack number two control
stress with andrew huberman an ability
to control your levels of stress in real
time is extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress
or calm here's how it works when you
inhale your diaphragm moves down
this creates more space in your thoracic
cavity and your heart
actually gets a little bit bigger as a
consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume
slows down a signal is sent from a group
of neurons on your heart
called the sinoatrial node that signal
goes up to the brain
and your brain sends a signal to speed
the heart up
in other words inhaling speeds your
heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves
up your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity
as a consequence blood flows more
quickly through that smaller volume
the sinoatrial node registers that and
sends a signal to your brain
and the brain sends a signal to slow the
heart down
so in other words inhaling speeds your
heart rate up
exhaling slows your heart rate down so
if you want to speed up your heart rate
and be more
alert inhale more or make those inhales
more vigorous more intense if you want
to calm down
you can do that quickly by making your
exhales slightly longer than your
inhales
or making them more vigorous this
doesn't require any breath work this is
something that you can do
in real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia
that's the technical phrase it's also
the basis of what's called
heart rate variability or hrv but all
you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up
exhaling longer and more intensely will
slow your heart rate down
and will allow you to calm down in real
time also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to 254 days
of consecutive action build a habit so
i'm going to be with you every step of
the way
if you want to be on for free 100 free
is the link below
go check it out i'll see you there and
so stop
resisting i encourage you stop resisting
the natural flow of epic performance
stop resisting the natural seasons of
life
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected hack number
three boost your
immunity with dr joe dispenza if you
have a
you know a a perception in your
outer environment of some type of danger
or threat
that the reaction or the response to
that stimulation
begins to activate the fight-or-flight
nervous system you're mobilizing
energy to prepare yourself for that
danger and when the body perceives that
danger it's a big threat
it doesn't hold back on the amount of
energy it's deciding to use it goes all
in
so for the short term that's fine but if
you keep doing it over and over again
you keep knocking your brain and body
out of balance and that's what stress is
and the rep the repetition of that keep
knocking the body out of balance
begins to weaken the organism so when a
person is perceiving
a danger threaten their outer world and
their turn on those adrenal hormones
they're putting all their energy for
that threat in their outer world there's
no energy in their inner world for
for repair for growth so a person who's
constantly feeling
fear because they believe something out
there is going to get them
then um they're more
more susceptible to things in their
outer environment than their immune
system is compromised
so they actually have more of a
propensity
for infections uh for foreign agents or
invaders because
now their body is reacting and
constantly responding to the outer world
so our research shows that if you trade
those emotions
of fear
of worry of anxiety of any vigilance
and you can open your heart and i know
that that doesn't seem
natural or normal during these times
but if not now when and
if you can begin to feel gratitude and
appreciation and settle your body
into the present moment four days of
feeling an elevated emotion would
actually strengthen your immune system
by about 50 we we've done the research
to show that once energy makes it into
your heart
the body begins to it's so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the emotion you're feeling by
thought alone and some emotion you would
feel
from some reaction in your environment
your body in that state is beginning to
believe it's safe enough
to relax into the present moment and and
so
when that occurs the immune system
begins to upregulate
and it begins to make these antibodies
and those antibodies are the body's
natural defense
against bacteria and viruses they're the
shields that protect
the body from foreign invaders and and
four days of doing that imagine if you
practice doing that
uh every single day i think by working
with your body and elevating your
emotional state
you could literally you could literally
become more resistant
uh or more um in in a state of order
independent of your outer environment
hack number four slow
down your aging with david sinclair
there are certain types of enzymes
that help package the dna and help with
the dna repair
these are the ones that are doing the
ping pong game and without those
we're screwed we basically will will age
more rapidly
conversely what's really exciting is is
we've discovered that
you can make them more active to make
sure the dna
is packaged correctly and the repair is
very efficient
and there are ways you can do that
exercise
dieting being hungry they allow these
enzymes that control
our body and make us healthier they make
those enzymes much more active so
instead of a pacman doing this
you exercise your diet take them take a
molecule that we work on
and it'll go around and fix everything
much more efficiently and keep you
younger for longer we think
i've been studying these enzymes the
sertuans we have seven in our bodies
i've been studying them for about 25
years
and what we've learned is that they
respond to the cellular
environment uh there's a chemical that
they require for
gas think of them as the fuel called nad
and there's another molecule that is
like the accelerator on the enzymes
uh that makes them going even faster and
that's one of them is called resveratrol
which we discovered years ago
from red wine and together they actually
do really
great things on these enzymes and make
them keep the body younger at least
for 25 years we've been studying mostly
um
animals and even little fungi yi cells
and what we've learned from those
studies is that these are largely
involved in responding to when organisms
are under threat
of survival so how do you make the body
feel like it's under threat
adversity so one is run a lot or at
least
become out of breath you know a few
times a week your body will say oh man
we had where to outpace one of those
sabertooth cats again
got to go to build up the body and the
other is to be hungry
either a couple of times a week or every
day you know skip a meal or two
and then your body will turn on these
sirtuins make more of that fuel
nad for the enzymes and we think that's
what's
in part responsible for the health
benefits of those uh lifestyle
choices and hack number five the last
one before very social bonus clip
is minimize anxiety with uma nedu
gluten can be problematic we've got
artificial sweeteners we've got sugar
um what are there other
sort of major things or are those like
are big to avoid that processed
vegetable or
for anxiety processed vegetable oils is
that okay so
um give me an example of where that
hides i think people will be surprised
how many things have that
exactly so you know it might be that a
restaurant look they they
tend to be oils that are less expensive
so
in the restaurant industry and in fast
food chains these are the oils that
that they use and reuse and it sets up
a huge level of inflammation of body
because what
changes is it flips the ratio of our
omega-6 to omega-3 fatty acids
and this is not good for us because what
that does is drives inflammation in the
body
here's a great example i have a few
clients who travel
a lot for work and contrary to what you
might think
during during the pandemic they start to
have a lower level of anxiety
and we noticed this specifically and i i
was puzzling me at first and then i
realized
you know just taking more and more
information and asking them i realized
that they were eating more meals at home
so even though they had been trying to
pursue a healthy diet following the
guidelines
and they had had an improvement in
anxiety they had a significant
improvement by eating meals at home
because they know
you know the oils i'm going to suggest
to them are yeah extra virgin olive oil
you know avocado oil
and one of the things that people don't
realize that is super helpful in
conditions like anxiety
is to up your fiber game um because
fiber
fiber rich foods break down in your body
i mean i don't need to tell you this
stuff
break down you know in a more complex
way more slowly so you don't
have you know think of the the sugary
doughnut and you know people have this
sugar crash and they plus they have a
sugar high then they have a sugar crash
it's all
about insulin bouncing all over the
place when you include
simple things like having more fiber
your your instrument is even
your blood sugar is even so people who
have anxiety don't have these
highs and lows other things about
anxiety are things
we know caffeine can drive anxiety but
it's the amount of caffeine it's how
your body tolerates it it's also
caffeine withdrawal
i've had people present with extremes of
anxiety because they come in saying
doctor i'm giving up caffeine and then
they have caffeine withdrawal and they
super anxious hydration
you know alcohol someone invites a
little bit too much
alcohol on a holiday weekend and the
next day somewhat dehydrated
can present with severe anxiety
hypoglycemia is another one just
you know someone who recently in my
practice was trying out a type of fast
i'm not against
the type of fasting i think it always
has to be discussed with their doctors
but didn't realize that they hit a very
low blood sugar level so they were
hypoglycemic and had panic attacks so
it's it's all you know we our physiology
is all interrelated you can't do one
thing without affecting something else
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're gonna do it
it jumps to 95 percent that you will
follow through so i want that for you
believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you it actually the 11 major risk
factors that steal your mind
if you're overweight you now have five
risk factors
the fat on your body is not your friend
it
stores toxins that's one risk factor
it increases inflammation that's another
risk factor
i published two studies that show as
your weight goes up
the blood flow to your brain goes down
which should scare the fat off anyone
that's three and
it takes healthy testosterone belly fat
and it flips it
it transforms it into unhealthy
cancer-promoting forms
of estrogen that's four
and then being overweight is five
and when you're overweight your blood
sugar often goes up as well
and that's part of being overweight so
it's
just like when i first figured it out i
always carried like 20 extra pounds um i
lost the weight
because i'm not going to shrink my brain
right i'm never going to do
anything i know purposefully to hurt
myself
why and it's like oh you're too uptight
it's like no it's because i love myself
why would i ever do something to hurt me
unless i was
sort of an idiot and i know that sounds
harsh
but now that you know we need to
be eating in a way that's calorie
smart and loaded with vegetables
there is a linear correlation to the
number of fruits and vegetables you eat
a day
and your level of happiness
[Music]
if you want the complete guide to
perfect health this year check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there they use their
shells the organisms within there
to keep out pathogens and to filter
stuff out that's exactly
what our noses do meditation is the
biggest gift that i can give anyone